Francisco shock 15 and here we go Liam
with the white pieces has to win this
game yeah it's a must-win situation and
he chooses the English opening as his
weapon Liam lay and it's the symmetrical
English that means white pushing a c
Pawn on move one and black basically
playing copycat black has adopted The
Identical setup that white has chosen
here black is castled quickly white has
chosen to play on the wing but Anish
doesn't seem surprised uh what do you
think Ivanka of this opening choice for
Liam especially in this muscle situation
very solid isn't it yeah and uh
definitely I do like this whole thing of
copycats
it totally is you know why it's going to
work on the left side black will also
try to do the same at some point and uh
it's I mean look at his King safety he's
completely safe yeah black Anish Gary
here he's gone safest houses with his
King he's ahead of development I'm
slightly surprised he pushed this Pawn I
thought he was going to start
challenging white Superior structure
we've seen a trade of Pawns and it's
gone in White's favor uh White has
traded off an Airborne for a sea Pawn
it's better to capture towards the
center but I'm pretty sure Anish over
the next few moves will try to fight
against that utilizing his lead in
development very symmetrical white is
about to Castle and each needs to be
quick yep and uh yeah these positions
have a reputation of being very balanced
but it's all about understanding who can
outmaneuver the opponent
and uh Liam I mean he's someone you've
interviewed before right he's uh one of
your favorite plays you mentioned yeah
definitely I mean what I like about him
is he has such a sharp tactical
aggressive style you know he's but he's
such a mild-mannered person I mean you
think you know what a great guy when you
chat to him he comes across as very
hard-working very disciplined he's also
great at uh he's now a head coach at
Webster he plans out the the chess
program
he's very very successful so I I do
quite like the fact that he's working
with the team or students and at the
same time improving his own game and
doing so well on the tour yeah and a
phenomenal player he's uh I grew up
playing him in his age groups he became
World Blitz champion
very very strong correct Instinct script
positional sense and yeah I love that
contradiction most chess players their
personality reflects their style but uh
with him it's uh yeah it's that
contradiction and uh okay anishikiri he
has fought back he's huge he's used the
time that white has taken to Castle to
try and initiate even more portraits and
we've gone back to symmetry complete
symmetry now in the position Anish he's
taking copy catches to a new level look
at this white moves a bishop he moves a
bishop white moves the queen will black
copy and move his screen oh are you
gonna see that I think we will yeah why
not why not yeah you can play a safe
move and it's actually good psychology
sometimes provoke your opponent oh God
but okay wait give us a chance Queen
moves back okay so there is one
potential tactical weakness on the board
and that is the loose piece on C6 yeah
Knight Black's night not defended
White's queen as well on an open file
may be targeted Yeah by a black rock
later I predict the white The Black
Queen just a step forward one square
protect it and line her up with the
bishop yeah I'll be very sensible it
feels like Anish he's mobilized all of
his pieces apart from the black queen
right now maybe apart from the Black
Brook next to his King get those pieces
into the game and why not keep copying
it's been working so far
so hard to imagine this going wrong for
black significantly
I mean the evaluation Bar says it's fine
for him maybe more than fine but when
you've copied your opponent basically
you have the same weaknesses they do you
have the same strengths they do and
those neutralize each other you'll move
on the board now your anchor yeah and
what can white do I just don't see any
way for Liam
to get active to create any kind of
imbalance to trick the opponent at all
and okay he activates his Rook
definitely that's a good move I I'm
actually expecting a niche to do the
same keep copying a niche your opponent
is trying to occupy the openc file you
can challenge that with the black book
and uh that's cool and here it comes and
I mean there is a potential plan of
actually the white Knights bringing
forward attacking the bishop yeah like
slight Square Bishop is a key piece so
if that could be traded off why not I
think Liam has to try something now
otherwise it's just too late
um I mean if we see a bunch of exchanges
on an open file if we see minor pieces
get swapped off if you have to retreat
that's not a good sign still the night
jump is in the air yeah
but he
got that
I think this should be a good idea
actually and there we go tonight no more
access to the G5 Square
this is safest houses Black's controlled
every Square on his half of the board
the top four ranks of the board
and Liam
I don't really understand what he's
doing he's controlling squares himself
but he's blocked in his own Bishop
White's Queen is passive
I understand why the computer chooses
black here and and she's trying to trade
off White's key piece that light Square
Bishop key defender of the king yeah and
I think that uh Liam should absolutely
refuse that exchange and step forward
but no he pushes his Pawn in the center
again again controlling more squares I'm
surprised by that move I didn't expect
it at all it's anti-positional we would
say in some regard because the light
squared Bishops are disappearing and the
only remaining Bishops on the board
white start Square Bishop is blocked in
by its own pawns white has created some
weak squares in his own camp on the
light squares there we go those Bishops
have traded a niche now with a
significant Advantage apparently
I would want to reroute the Black
Knights it might take a while but I
think you do have that luxury it's still
relatively blocked white king as well as
on a slightly open diagonal so Black's
Queen if it slides across two squares to
the left will peer down at that white
king in many variations
so that could be one idea if we do look
at the clock times though Liam is a
minute ahead Anish he has had a small
tendency to crack under the pressure the
time pressure in these Blitz tie breaks
throughout the season
so um will that come back to haunting I
think that's his best chance now Liam to
hustle on the clock yeah and uh I love
this move by Anish I mean just simply
moving his Queen lining up on the same
diagonal as the white king
and computer doesn't like it but it
looks very human very natural and uh at
least it will provoke Liam into a bit of
a longer think yeah I just hate White's
Bishop White's Bishop is just a dead
block of wood
I agree it doesn't look great but then
again maybe you can move itself to the
E1 Square
save itself for later exactly
um and in the meantime I mean black has
a great Square for the night if you
could put itself on C4 then black has a
little chances to win yeah that C4
Outpost would be Dynamite if a knight
can get there I'm just looking at Liam's
camera is that a picture of his own face
behind him like a I think it is
someone's done a drawing of him it is
he's watching over himself for this game
hoping to give himself some luck he's
got the tiniest neatest so you know most
professional office I know yeah he
actually posted a picture of his office
from the side view on Twitter recently
and I took a picture of that as
inspiration just I want to set up my
office anyway it's just
so nicely arranged and Black's night is
coming around White's Bishop does
retreat as you mentioned Ivanka it was
stuck where it was anyway and Black's
Night On The Edge the night on the rim
is pretty dim right now but if it can
re-route eventually to C4 and that would
just be beautiful for black no risk
I think the okay he just moves his Rook
forward planning to double along the sea
line
very good strategy
it's difficult to see a way for Liam to
put black under some pressure how do you
even improve White's pieces without
allowing exchanges White's night on the
sea file is vulnerable but if you have a
retreat Rooks are coming off the board
the drawers getting closer for Anish
Gary and the desire the resultant okay
he's taking risks now Liam this comes
with a significant risk definitely I
learned a good rule of thumb if you're
going to push your Pawn into enemy
territory you have to make sure that you
can protect it you've got to protect
your children is the expression and uh
here we go Rooks are doubled yeah it
just feels weird white white gaining
space in the center when look at White's
pieces nearly all of them are on the
back rank so not really protecting uh
that pawn still no direct threats I
think for black I don't think you can
try and take that pawn anytime soon but
it's still hard for them to move
and uh I mean your Rooks are very stuck
your nights are a bit stuck right now
you're porn in the middle of the board
that white deep one
it's vulnerable it is vulnerable and not
only that
horn move also did a great thing for the
dark Square Bishop that black has it's
now got a long diagonal to look at
before it was just biting on wood yeah
biting on granite is the expression
black starts with a bishop yeah it's got
great potential more potential than
white slurry piece on the first rank at
least and now clock times earlier Liam
had a one minute time advantage to at
least compensate for his slightly shaky
position but that's gone now it's almost
a minute disadvantage for Liam and
struggling on the board
he really looks so focused uh he looks
so good in this tiebreak I must say
that's probably the best we've seen
anishagiri and Blitz at least this
season on the tour he's been playing a
lot recently he got to the semi-finals
of the global Chess Championship
yeah he's
at least not Rusty that's one thing for
Anish he's had quite a few near misses
as well on on the tour you know he's
some critical moments that he hasn't
quite managed to do anything and of
course he did badly in Miami he also
didn't do so great in the OZO Esports
losing in critical moments and yeah and
of course this uh heartbreak in the
global championships so maybe he's kind
of reached that point where he's like
okay I don't care anymore and sometimes
you just have to reach that breaking
point and then you can suddenly recover
life is strange that way yeah it's a
good mentality just forget just get
immersed in the position stop thinking
about the emotions the history
everything that's gone wrong
sometimes you need to lose a few times
in order to bounce back and okay Liam
has installed his Knight in the center
of the board this white knight now in
the middle combined with the port in
front of it are a great pair if White's
Knight can leap forward but maybe
tactically does this work I was gonna
say I mean there's a pawn up for grabs
yeah can he take it some calculation
needs to be done it feels like Liam is
bluffing he's saying to Anish I don't
think you can take my Pawn button each
calls the bluff
does capture in the center frowning in
each giri as well it looks like Black's
Knights are hanging Black's night on the
edge of the board as well very loose but
there's no way to take advantage if this
black knight in the middle is captured
as it is then all the Rooks are coming
off the board
hey guys there we go and another one
leaves the board yeah and then uh is
vicious again an Intermezzo as we call
it in between move forward tonight gave
itself up with a check but here it feels
like Black's pieces are better than
white so at least the Bishops
however Black's night is not great uh
right now it doesn't make a nice
impression and okay Bishop takes Knight
we see a bad Bishop for white versus a
potentially good knight but Black Knight
takes a few moves to get to a good
Square
activation there activating that black
queen as the first step looks very solid
looks great actually and I do love
Leanne's last move it's such a
what do you call it disrupter move
pushing that pawn forward breaking the
coordination and now it can take the
pawn uh by Queen
very close to the black king next threat
is uh the bishop is going to move to the
C3 square and suddenly it's going to be
deadly checkmates ideas on the G7 Square
and an issues allowing White's Bishop to
activate I think anisha's plan if the
white Bishop moves as it has just done
there's a threat of Checkmate on the
board White Queen wants to go up to the
corner step next to the black king
Checkmate there's also a Checkmate on
the G7 Square two different mates
threatened but Anish surely his idea now
is to start checking the white king just
give checks as long as you can
um there's also an idea of putting the
Black Knight in the middle of the board
blocking this white Bishop maybe that's
his actual plan looks good
maybe it's safer to block with the
Knight yeah the black queen can't give
too many checks actually I I would do
that
and not much time left for a niche just
under 20 seconds and he does block the
diagonal and we do see a trade of pieces
this is looking great for Anish he is on
course for drawing the game yeah this is
reminiscent of a queen end game we saw
earlier today between Magnus Carlsen and
Wesley so this one is even more balanced
though because neither side has a Plus
Pawn and you mentioned it looks great
for Gary because his Queen is more
centralized than his counterpart
yeah I I think if Gary loses this one
it would be the biggest shock we've seen
on the tour simply because it is almost
an unusable position
um he's advancing forward with his pawns
Black's King is now slightly exposed to
some checks but remember checks are
Perpetual for example would result in a
draw which would give Gary the match win
White's king is not entirely safe either
between centralizing itself going after
the weakness on the F2 Square White's
Queen is far far away from
protecting his King
yes he's headed towards a draw it is
headed towards the draw and a normal
world so these two would have agreed to
draw a long long time ago but of course
for Liam he's in a must-win situation so
draw is the same as a loss
the promise he can't really keep the
game going Liam because Black's Queen is
staring at two different pawns and the
poor near the white king but also at the
B4 pawn and you can't save both if you
can't save both either you've got to
accept a draw now or you're going to go
down upon and probably just lose the
game and I think we'll see Liam access
to the draw because there's nothing else
to do
no creation of a passport no good checks
and White's King is offside and he's
under 10 seconds there throwing in some
checks I think you're right David you
can see a result any second now yeah
great result for Anish Geary
disappointment with William but he tried
he pushed Gary to the Limit here okay
he's gonna keep trying maybe he's
playing for the loss more than the uh
win here look at this he's just given up
a pawn
suddenly black is the only one who can
win this position
black has a pass to be Pawn we will
still see a draw I think Gary's not
going to risk it by walking away with
the black king
and if you don't run away from the
checks
position just repeats itself
yeah and uh Gary's happy to sit on these
two squares he knows that there's
nothing else Liam can do he's just like
the games earlier he's attacking with
only a queen and it is a draw
ing
takes the